the dragon that I'm jostling against
this year is this frozen monopoly of the
two parties there that are frozen a lot
of people's thinking in place and they
think I have to be a right wing or I
have to be a left wing they're not
thinking what do I think I am Nicholas B
with reason TV and today we're talking
with William weld former governor of
Massachusetts and vice presidential
candidate for the Libertarian Party and
Gary Johnson former governor of New
Mexico and the presidential candidate
nominee of the Libertarian Party at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas thank you guys
for talking yeah thanks let's get right
at it you are according to a new year of
most recent New York Times Paul you're
at 12% why is that happening and where
does it end it's happening because first
and foremost arguably two most
polarizing figures in American politics
today Trump and Clinton so that's the
primary factor but then secondarily
two Republican governors two-term
getting reelect getting re-elected in
states that are heavily Democratic I
mean I think there's a lot a lot here in
the libertarian ticket i think i think
we're reflective of most americans which
speaking with a broad brush stroke as
being fiscally conservative and socially
tolerant liberal whatever as long as you
don't force it on me and a big
unoccupied space to is is nobody
standing up and saying let's stop
dropping bombs let's stop with the
military interventions that they're
having the unintended consequence of
making things worse not better there's
no peace candidate what is the worst
aspect of a potential trump presidency
and what's the worst aspect of a
potential Clinton presidency I'll start
with Trump you know III don't think that
mr. Trump has made a great study of the
issues I'm not sure that he's read
deeply in history as it might apply to
current political decisions so I I see a
shallowness so we'll talk about
immigration how to you know isn't that
what people want you know they want to
restrict immigration they want to
restrict restrict Syrians or
Arabs or Muslims you know having been in
New Hampshire and having been in the
Midwest what I have recognized is that
30% of
publican voters believe the scourge of
the earth is Mexican immigration now it
was my voice in 2012 that said no it's
not the case but I know that that group
exists and when things are bad you know
you look for a scapegoat and in this
case they're taking jobs that US
citizens could have well no they're not
they're not murderers and rapists and
the notion of rounding up 11 million
undocumented workers how's that gonna
work out in New Mexico where 50% of the
population is Hispanic well they're
gonna federal governments because start
knocking on doors it goes on and on but
the other thing is the rule of law in
the Constitution and we pride ourselves
on the rule of law in this country not
only socially in terms of our government
but also our economy both domestic and
foreign and mr. Trump is suggested he
would slap a 45 percent tariff on
Chinese goods 35% tariff on Mexican
goods build a huge wall and make the
Mexicans pay for it any number of things
that would violate his duties under the
Constitution he sent a fundraising
letter to members of foreign
legislatures that's a violation the
emoluments closed we would be hauled
before the court of international
justice at Hague as a rogue nation if we
did everything that Donald Trump has
proposed in the area of foreign policy
I'm not kidding I know I was gonna say I
think the hague will be the least of our
problems right in the court of
international opinion but Hillary
Clinton now you talk about protectionism
Hillary Clinton is against she's talking
down NAFTA she has she started doing
that with only free trade ticket yeah up
there okay so so what what is
particularly bad about Hillary Clinton I
mean she's a protectionist too what else
what would be terrible about a Hillary
Clinton presidency that that she is the
establishment nothing's gonna cheer
gonna change government's gonna try and
do more in our lives as opposed to less
and so that's gonna mean higher taxes
that's money out of your in my pocket
that we could be spending on our own
lives as opposed to government knows
best and she is really and I don't think
that this has been intentional but she's
really been the architect of our foreign
policy that has made things worse not
better using Syria and Libya as an
example you know going in and
hoarding the opposition in those two
countries that are aligned with Isis you
can't make this up this is what has
happened say something negative about
Hillary Clinton you've been you've been
dinged in the press you seem very I mean
you're friendly with her and you you
like her as a as a person but oh I'm old
friends with both Clintons but election
time at the end of the day there are no
friends okay the first thing I would say
is just a fiscal situation when
President Obama leaves office the
national debt is going to be 20 trillion
dollars doubled since not so long ago
you can't go on like that you can't go
and try to renegotiate the terms of our
national debt with the Chinese that's
Trump not clear-eyed I think it's
something that she truly believes that
she would like to raise the amount of
social spending raise the amount of
government spending called investment on
the other on the Democratic side of the
aisle and I think that'd be bad for the
economy it would hollow out the economy
we're small government people we cut
taxes we shrank government the Democrats
would go the other direction you know
we're spending about four trillion
dollars a year the federal government in
the first budget that is signed by
Johnson weld Administration how much are
you gonna spend and where do you where
do you take it from you cannot do the
Washington thing of assuming that
anything other than a 5% increase is a
cut that's Washington speak and that's
what the two-party duopoly has gotten us
into both parties if you only have a 2%
rate of growth in government overall
government spending you balance the
budget in five years and you would
freeze spending or keep it below 2%
annually we would come out of the chute
proposing a balanced budget 20% of
government spending is becoming debt
would you cut 20% proposing proposing a
balanced budget yes which would in fact
target a 20% it's not a bad goal you
know I think I've been around government
a long time for my sins and I think
between 10 and 20 percent of most
budgets are overspent people in
Washington particularly do not
understand there's no such thing as
government money there's only taxpayers
money they think it's their money you
can't do it without addressing military
spending you can't do it without Andres
addressing the entitlements Medicaid and
Medicare Social Security raising the
retirement age you could have a very
fair means testing to go along so you're
putting it's not even that you're saying
you're putting it all on the table what
you're saying is that yeah you're gonna
cut defense spending you're gonna cut
entitlements military spending III think
defense is a knock you know but you know
we're not just saying this we did it my
first year in office we cut spending in
real dollars what did you what did you
cut what you have to do is zero base the
budget you assume every appropriate
appropriation is zero when you start the
year that's why it helped both of us our
first job and elected politics was
governor so we didn't know there were
sacred cows in the budget we didn't even
know they were cows and the same thing
would be true in Washington
we're planning a partnership in this
also no separate staffs you know staffs
secret event and you guys aren't sick of
each other yet no no actually it's a
kind of eyebrows for seven seven years
with my lieutenant governor we never had
an argument governor Johnson what was
the big thing you cut in New Mexico and
and you did not cut spending you know
you know what was the toughest thing
what was the toughest reaction that you
it wasn't tough but we reformed Medicaid
in the state of New Mexico and get this
I had an insurance policy as governor of
New Mexico for my family provided for me
by the state G what if we took my
insurance policy and gave it to
everybody that was receiving Medicaid
would we actually cut the cost of
Medicaid by 20% so how do you do that
how do you do that and if you're your
president vice president you're dealing
with Obama care do you repeal Obama care
what happens well of course you know
we're looking to get elected president
and vice president not dictator not the
king but that said whatever comes out of
Congress is what you ultimately end up
supporting or not supporting so with
regard to Medicaid and Medicare the only
way in my opinion that we reform these
two areas are to give these areas from a
service standpoint up to the States
and having been governor of New Mexico
in my heart of hearts if the federal
government would have given me a fixed
amount of money same amount as the year
before I could have drawn new lines
there would have been a safety net
nobody would have gone without but
that's how you get it done Washington
one size fits all I don't think it's
possible another couple of touchstones
putting more a personal choice into the
healthcare area more competition letting
people shop across state lines
I wouldn't let people shop into Canada
it wouldn't shock my conscience on how
you cut the budget a lot two very quick
examples from Massachusetts we put in a
work requirement for welfare so you have
to have a job if you're gonna get
welfare welfare costs went down over 75%
then next year people were not ready for
that we did the same thing when I was a
prosecutor i convicted a lot of people
for phony pensions they would say I
slipped and fell I want a million
dollars so I convicted three people in
Criminal Court in Boston the next year
the number of disability pensions filed
four went down by over 75% huge cost
savings and it wasn't a budgetary thing
it was a qualitative thing the Supreme
Court looms large in everybody's
political calculations who are the
Supreme Court picks you're gonna make
well I'm gonna I'm gonna turn this over
to Bill this really being his valor wick
but really there are gonna be no litmus
tests you're gonna appoint good people
and you're gonna appoint people that
look at the Constitution from the
standpoint of original intent I don't
think we have to panic and say it has to
be a way left or way righty
Steve Breyer has been a good justice he
was appointed by a Democrat
Massachusetts guy rights guy Merrick
garland I think would have been a very
good pick and he's nominated by Obama I
mean everyone sort of agrees on that I
think the two-party hysteria that says
just like you can only have far-right
congressmen and the Republican Party and
far far left congressman congresswoman
in the Democratic Party therefore the
same is true for the Supreme Court the
opposite is the case
you want people who are tranquil of mind
who can analyze the issues and come to a
conclusion that makes sense rooted in
the jurisprudence of our country going
back hundreds of years
you mentioned far right and far left
people in Congress who are who are
current members of the Senate and the
house that you think you could work with
because if you guys come in obviously
you're you're not gonna have a
libertarian Congress I think there's a
real opportunity to not naming names but
just name names name names Rob Portman
obviously Kelly Ayotte Susan Collins the
best of all Mark Kirk on the Republican
side a guy he's a challenger Russ
Feingold in Wisconsin not saying I'm
endorsing him but he's obviously a
person of substantial abilities but I
you name people like Collins but you
know most most Republicans and even I
think most libertarians would say Susan
Collins is terrible she votes for more
spending she is not great on the second
amendment she's a wishy-washy you know
kind of country-club conservative yeah
you disagree though yeah I'm gonna say
you challenged Republicans to be good at
what they're supposed to be good at
which is dollars and cents and they're
not good at that at all because they
pick and choose they want to cut it from
Planned Parenthood but they want to
increase the military budget well gee
that just doesn't work and then
Democrats look come on
let's stop dropping bombs let's really
take a hard look at our military policy
let's get Congress involved in a
declaration of war and how we move
forward and mandatory sentencing ending
the drug war come on this is a huge
issue these are things that they should
be good at they're not good at either
let's talk about Washington if we win if
we get in there I think it might almost
be a relief for members of Congress to
have us not being tendentious not coming
in saying this is how it's got to be we
will hire the best of the Democratic
party the best of the Republican party
the best of the Libertarian Party and
the best of all those who are
unaffiliated with any party I almost
think that would be appreciated by
Congress so they won't have to think
what does my party say I'm supposed to
do they'll be able to think what should
I do
that would be a big change and I just
tweak that a little bit Republicans
Democrats with a libertarian bent
Trump and Hillary Clinton as you
mentioned historically high disapproval
ratings nobody nobody likes them even in
their own parties what is the pitch to
Democrats don't vote for Hillary vote
for Johnson well the whole honesty and
integrity and telling the truth I think
we've had careers based on telling the
truth and when you tell the truth that's
admitting mistakes also make plenty of
mistakes but Hillary does not tell the
truth well I I think there's a judgment
issue that if I were to have made those
same judgment issues I'd like to think
that whoa I made some really poor
judgment here guilty guilty of the
judgment not guilty of criminal intent I
that was not the case but that's not
something I think you hear her say
what's the case to Republicans who
cannot bring themselves to vote for
Donald Trump or actually might be
thinking about it what what do you say
why she libertine same thing look you
know there is a there is a path down the
middle here that really does address
smaller government the smaller
government is something that is
desirable that liberty and freedom is
important and it and it means that you
can be a social conservative but don't
try and force that on me and and I get
the pressures that come with being in
elected office and shouldn't we bomb
Isis and knee-jerk is always yes and so
it's drop bombs first as opposed to
let's look at how that might work out
over a long period of time what about
Bernie Sanders he is a progressive he's
a social progressive he wants to grow
government what is the pitch that you
guys make to disgruntled Bernie bros to
vote for you take the ice side with
dot-com quiz see if you turn out like me
I've sided with myself most and then
next in line I side with Bernie Sanders
but here's my contention our Bernie
Sanders supporters really about income
equality or are they about opportunity
equality and if they're about
opportunity equality
and this is really this is crony
capitalism this is the fact that
government is for sale it's being sold
you got money you can buy influence and
you can you can buy prosperity well
we're gonna offer up a big dose of
government can provide equal opportunity
and if people see that I think that's
more important or that is something
that's achievable even more than any one
issue I think the dragon that I'm
jostling against this year is this
frozen monopoly of the two parties there
that have frozen a lot of people's
thinking in place and they think I have
to be a right wing or I have to be a
left winger they're not thinking what do
I think and if we can shatter that and
get them asking the question what do I
think and then listen to the the three
offerings
they're gonna come our way and I don't
mean 20% of them I mean between 40 and
50% of them and that's the election
you're traveling all over the country
who what are the types of people that
are connecting with you the most you
know that we have people coming up and
saying I didn't know I was a libertarian
until I heard you guys talking who are
those people hundred people a day
hundred people a day Democrats
Republicans independents so elements
what how our young people responding to
this message you saw the poll the other
day we're polling higher among
Millennials than Donald Trump why do you
think that is well I think this is the
notion of being socially who cares as
long as those choices don't adversely
affect others dropping bombs I think
young people recognize that the world
isn't a safer place at all for all of
what we're doing overseas and then I
really do believe that young people
recognize that the system is rigged that
in my opinion is not income equality
that's equal opportunity and that we can
offer up a big dose of that you know I
hadn't thought of it this way before but
we're both young at heart we haven't had
that squeezed out of us yeah talk about
the future you know one of the things
that is interesting is that both Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump you know
they're not that much older than you you
got
are all baby boomers of one stripe or
another but they never talk about the
future they don't even talk about things
like uber or the sharing economy unless
they're saying that it needs to be
regulated and shut down what is your
what is your vision of a future America
let me start with the present has has
life in America ever been better than it
is today no it hasn't we get along
better kids are smarter than ever the
number one law enforcement tool is this
guy right here when we're witnessing
that all the time when you think about
the future and you think about a model
of entrepreneurism where the middleman
can be eliminated and you as a provider
of goods and services can make more
money and people that are buying those
services pay less
that's an excite or B and B we Kate and
I we have a home in Santa Fe I think we
could rent that darn thing out part time
for make an extra 40 grand a year will
the city of Santa Fe bands air B&B
come on if that was money in our pockets
we'd be spending that all over Santa Fe
well they're protecting the the hotel
industry and I think there's a closed
mindedness with Democrats and
Republicans you know protect the status
quo when future is wide open if we'll
just get a libertarian bent on the whole
thing we are going to leave it there
thank you so much we have been talking
with governor Gary Johnson running as
the libertarian nominee for president
and governor William weld the vice
presidential libertarian nominee thanks
so much thank you so much thank you so
much for recent TV I'm Nikolas